and finally new role some conservative
somewhere has to explain to me why they
think Barack Obama doesn't love America
because every time I hear him talk about
America my reaction is get a room he
says things like you know where the
country on earth is my story even
possible and America remains the one
indispensable nation and yet 69 percent
of Republicans say he doesn't love our
country and only 11 percent say he loves
it the right way but what is the right
way how much should we love our country
and how often what if we want to love it
but it's tired and had a long day and
most importantly should we love it from
behind or is that to me
now for the last couple of weeks as the
oceans die the debt balloons and we skid
back into Iraq Republicans have been
obsessed with a much bigger issue
disappointed at what it started with
America's Mayor Rudy Giuliani who employ
it does kind of look like you Rudy
Giuliani who implied that if you
criticize America in any way it means
you don't love her but that's not how
grown-ups think about a country it's the
way thirteen-year-old girls think about
one direction Obama loves America it
just doesn't make him do this because
he's an adult and he knows the
difference between his country and his
mommy liberals love America plenty they
just think Paris is a more interesting
vacation spot than Branson
I have no problem listening what I love
about my country for one we aren't ruled
by a hereditary monarchy the bushes and
Clinton's take turns - we come to the
aid of people in need I mean you know on
a case-by-case basis
sorry Rwanda will get you next done and
three two words freedom face it we
complain but if you had a choice of any
country to be born in for the last 200
years you'd choose
well Canada but after that totally the
US of A which is not to say we're
perfect there's a lot to love about it
and a lot not to like our legacy of
genocide slavery and racism or income
inequality militarism environmental
damage and the worst mass incarceration
on earth we lead the world at obesity
and use 19 percent of the world's energy
just getting up the stairs
don't get me started on the guys who
paint your house number on the curb
without asking first I mean
but there I go
loving my country in the wrong way with
my head instead of my heart which is how
conservatives do it they love America
like like those parents who think their
kid can never do wrong when a note comes
home from school reporting bad behavior
they go in and yell at the teacher or in
the case of the school board in Oklahoma
yell at the people who wrote the
American history textbook yes the
conservatives in Oklahoma these days
were waging a battle to get rid of the
current textbook because they say it
focuses too much on negative aspects in
America's past like it mentions Japanese
internment camps why bring that up it's
just gonna make things awkward down at
the Sochi play
when it comes to American conservatives
they're a little like blackout drinkers
they remember all the good stuff about
the night before the laughs the winning
at beer pong but no recollection of the
bad the pissing in the lobby fountain
groping co-workers wiping out the
Indians which which is a shame because
you can't turn the page on America's bad
stuff if you won't print the page to
begin with if you won't acknowledge that
many of the good things America has done
are actually reversals of bad things
America did I think it's great that we
gave the Indians the casino business in
America and I'm proud of the
Emancipation Proclamation I'm proud of
women's suffrage of the Civil Rights Act
of legal gay marriage in 37 states and
Counting but all of that wouldn't have
been necessary if we hadn't been dicks
in the first place